Let’s consider the problem of trying to
find a face in a crowd and, in particular,
I want to find the face of the robot Bender.
Here he is: he is hiding behind a Dalek and
standing next to Eve. So rather than us having
to scan the crowd to find Bender, let’s
see if we can automate the task.
We are going to use the spatial operator approach
in order to solve this problem. What we are
going to do is for every input window we are
going to compare it with a template image,
the template being the image, the pattern
we are looking for and our function now is
a similarity function. We are going to look
at the similarity between the particular input
window which marches across the image left
to right, top to bottom. Every input window
we are going to compare it with, our template
and the similarity score is going to be placed
into the output image. So the template will
be the face of Bender and we are going to
compare the face of Bender at every single
location across the scene. So how do we compare
two images, how do we tell that a particular
input window W looks like Bender or doesn’t
look like Bender?
To do this we need an image similarity measure
and the simplest one is called the sum of
absolute differences, sometimes abbreviated
to SAD or sad() and quite simply we take the
difference between the corresponding pixels
in the two images that we are trying to compare.
Of course, they must be the same size, take
their absolute value and sum it up. So if
the images are identical, the similarity measure
will have a value of 0. If they are dissimilar,
S will have a value greater than 0. So 0 means
perfect match; a big value means a less perfect
match. A quite similar approach is the operator
called ssd(), sum of square differences, and
instead of using the absolute value operation
we are taking the sum of the squares.
Another measure is the zero mean normalised
cross correlation, commonly abbreviated to
zncc(). It looks much more complicated, but
it has some advantages over the two simple
measures above. The zncc() measure varies
from -1 to +1. +1 means that the images are
identical and -1 means that one image is the
negative of the other one. 0 means that the
two images are not very well correlated.
Typically, a value above 0.8 is considered
to be a reasonable match. Here we revisit
the original puzzle and there is Bender highlighted.
So we first of all need to create the template,
so here I have chopped Bender out of the scene,
so it is mostly Bender and a few of his neighbours
as well.
And then what I am going to do is to use a
Photoshop-like program to remove all of the
robots in that scene that are not Bender.
I am going to zoom in as much as I can on
his head and blacken out all of the other
robots that I am not interested in. So this
is the template, this is the pattern that
I am going to go looking for in the image.
The first thing I am going to do is load the
crowd scene into a workspace variable which
I am going to call crowd. I am going to load
it from the file wheres_walle.png, it is a
PNG format file. I want to convert the colour
image to grey scale and I want to convert
all the pixels to double precision values.
That is, they lie between 0 and 1 and then
let’s display that.
And there we see the crowd scene, next I am
going to load an image of the robot Bender
and that is in a PNG file also; going to convert
that to double precision and I have loaded
that into the workspace variable Bender. We
can see that it is a very small image; it
has only got 55 rows of pixels and 41 columns of pixels. Let’s display that in a new window.
And that is our template. So the problem to
hand is to look for that particular template
pattern in every possible location in the
input image. So this is a really big searching
problem. To do that I am going to use the
tool box function called isimilarity and I
pass in the image of Bender, the template
that we are looking for, the scene in which
I am searching for the template and the last
argument is the similarity measure—we just
talked about similarity measures—and I am
going to use the zncc measure, zero mean normalise
cross correlation, which is perhaps the Rolls
Royce of image similarity measures, and I
am going to compute that on my rather nice
laptop. This calculation takes about 90 something
seconds so we are going to skip through to
the end. Great, we are done. So we have computed
the variable S. It is a large matrix and we
can consider it to be an image and display
it as such and this is a similarity image.
Now what we have here is this similarity measure,
so let’s just click around in a few points
and we can see that these pixels that I am
clicking on have got quite low similarity
measure. It means that where I have clicked
the template is not at all a good fit.
Down here we can see some similarity values
that are a little bit bigger, 0.44, 0.47.
The maximum value similarity is 1. So at this
location it is possible that the template
exists but it is not a marvellous fit. We
can see some places that are quite dark where
it is certainly is very poor fit. In fact
it is a negative similarity measure. But somewhere
in here there will be some very bright pixels
which represent where the template fits best.
So this is a very large matrix: there’s
almost a million numbers in here and what
we have to do is to find the biggest number
within this matrix.
Now we have a tool box function which can
do that for us and it’s used like this.
So it has got two output variables and I will
explain them in just a moment.
The function is called peak2 and we pass in
the similarity image. Pass in the argument
one which is saying that we want to find the
brightest pixel, that is, the brightest pixel
with respect to all of the pixels who are
one pixel away from it. So it is like, it’s
the brightest within a very local region and
let’s ask for the five brightest peaks in
descending order. So that’s the brightest
pixel, the second brightest pixel and so on.
Takes a moment to compute; and what we see
is we have computed two output variables,
now the first one, the one we call MX or maximum
is the value of that brightest pixel and the
corresponding column in the matrix P is the
coordinate of that brightest pixel.
So what it is saying is within that similarity
image the greatest similarity that it has
found has got a value of 0.6107 and it occurs
at a U coordinate of 331 and a V coordinate
of 364. The second best fit has got a similarity
of 0.5580 and we can see its coordinate, third
best fit, fourth best fit, fifth best fit
and so on.
So in order to visualise that, what we can
do is to select the original image and what
I am going to do is to plot some circles on
this image that indicate where we found these
good fits. So this is rather a lot of arguments
to this function, but basically it is saying
plot a circle of radius 30 pixels and plot
one of these circles for every column in the
matrix piece. So it is going to plot 5 circles.
I want the circles to be coloured blue. I
want them to be translucent, so we set the
alpha value for these circles to 0.3, which
means that they are see through circles and
that they do not have any edge colour and
here we go, there is a blue circle on every
place where we think the robot Bender is.
Now let’s also indicate the rank of the
selections; another rather complex function
core, but it’s basically saying for every
point P, I want to put a sequential number
in a bold font text size 36, in yellow writing
and here we go, so we can see the first best
fit, second best fit, third, fourth and fifth
and we can see that the blue circle with the
number one next to it is indeed the robot
Bender … we are looking closely enough;
we can see Bender’s happy face there.
We are going to extract a region of the crowd
scene around where we located the robot Bender.
We are going to do that by using the iroi
function, the region of interest function.
And to pass in the entire image, the crowd
image, we are going to pass in the coordinate
of the point where the template had the best
match, that is, the first column of the matrix
P. Each column of the matrix P represents
a point in the image where the template fitted
either first best, second best and so on.
So the first column is the point where the
template fitted the best and we are going
to extract a region which is 50 pixels square
and so here we see the region of the crowd
scene where we found the robot Bender and
on the right we see the template of Bender.
We can see that these regions are not quite
the same. But we are showing on the left a
pattern of pixels where the template fitted
the best.
So what I have done is to take the original
image of the crowd scene and I have cut out
a bunch of pixels which has Bender’s face
in it, I have gone into Photoshop and I have
blacked out some of the background which is
not relevant—they are not part of Bender,
they are actually part of the robots around
Bender—and that is how I found the template.
So if I applied this template to a different
robot crowd scene and perhaps, in that crowd
scene, Bender didn’t have a cigar; perhaps
he was looking in another direction; perhaps
he was closer to the camera and appeared to
be bigger, or he was further away and appeared
to be smaller. Then a simple-minded template
matching technique like this is not going
to work particularly well.